Jumanji: The Next Level is almost here, and
we've got a fresh batch of character posters
to get you psyched - along with one for a
mysterious new character… and another for
a horse.
"You guys!
We're back!
In Jumanji!"
The gang - or, rather, their avatars - are
all here: Kevin Hart's Franklin "Mouse" Finbar,
Karen Gillan's Ruby Roundhouse, Jack Black's
Professor Sheldon "Shelly" Oberon, Nick Jonas'
Jefferson "Seaplane" McDonough, and the absolutely
brilliantly named Dr. Smolder Bravestone,
played, of course, by Dwayne Johnson.
As for the new addition, we don't yet know
her name, or whether she's a player avatar
or an NPC - but she'll be portrayed by the
suddenly ubiquitous Awkwafina.
Oh, and did we mention a horse, you ask?
Yes, yes we did - and if you've seen the final
trailer for the flick, then you know that
there's a darn good reason for the steed to
have its own character poster.
"Bethany thought you might need some help."
"Where is Bethany?"
"She's right here."
"She says, 'Oh my God.
Like, I'm a total horse.'"
"Yup, that's Bethany."
"Heeeeeey."
Just in case you're uninitiated, or need a
brief refresher: in 2017's Jumanji: Welcome
to the Jungle, a group of five teens find
themselves sucked into a jungle-themed video
game that must be completed before you can
escape it.
Alex Wolff's Spencer finds himself controlling
Bravestone, Madison Iseman's Bethany is stuck
with Professor Oberon, Ser'Darius Blain's
Anthony "Fridge" Johnson gets "Mouse" Finbar,
and Morgan Turner's Martha lucks out with
Ruby Roundhouse, the game's most kickass character.
Together, they discover that a boy named Alex
- portrayed by Mason Guccione as a teen and
Colin Hanks as an adult - has been trapped
in the game for over 20 years, piloting the
avatar of "Seaplane" McDonough.
They must help him to retrieve an in-game
artifact known as the "Jaguar's Eye," defeat
villainous NPC Russell Van Pelt - played by
Bobby Cannavale - and finish the game before
the jungle finishes them.
This time around, the entire young cast is
returning - but there's an interesting new
wrinkle.
When Spencer repairs the game, which the teens
smashed at the end of the first film, and
inadvertently re-enters it, his friends come
to the rescue - but unfortunately, only Martha
and Fridge make it, and Martha is the only
player controlling the same avatar as last
time.
Fridge winds up with the portly, ineffective
Professor Oberon, and Spencer's grandfather
Eddie - played by Danny DeVito - and his friend
Milo, portrayed by Danny Glover, are accidentally
brought along for the ride, controlling Bravestone
and Finbar, respectively.
"You're Spencer's grandfather."
"Are we in Florida."
"And you…"
"Milo Walker.
Did I die… and turn into some kind of small,
muscular boy scout?"
The trailers reveal that this gives Hart and
Johnson room to really flex their comedic
chops in channeling Glover and DeVito's personas
- and that there'll be an intriguing change
of setting or two at some point, from the
jungle to the desert.
The posters also indicate that our heroes
may have to contend with some bitter cold
locale along the way.
Case in point: this poster featuring Professor
Oberon, who looks absolutely psyched to be
someplace that could in no way be described
as sunny, sandy, or hot.
A little bit chilly, sure, but psyched nonetheless.
"Weaknesses: Heat, sun, and sand.
How is THIS GUY a character in an adventure
game?"
Here's "Mouse," looking about as confounded
as you would be if you were a septuagenarian
grandpa who suddenly found yourself transported
into the world of one of those newfangled
video games.
We only briefly hear Hart's impersonation
of Glover in the trailers, but boy, is it
ever spot-on.
Next up: Gillan as Ruby Roundhouse, looking
as badass as ever.
We can't help but point out that it will never
stop blowing our minds that this is the same
actress who portrays Nebula in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, and it "only" takes about
3-5 hours in the makeup chair to render her
completely unrecognizable - and somehow even
more badass.
Here's Jonas as "Seaplane" McDonough.
This time around, it'll be Spencer controlling
the avatar, although Hanks will return as
the adult version of Alex, who had the dubious
honor of being stuck as "Seaplane" for a couple
of decades.
Ah yes, and here's the horse… although it
is not just a horse.
It's actually an avatar, and - spoiler alert
- for at least part of the movie, it's controlled
by Bethany.
Then there's Awkwafina's new character, who
is seen only briefly in the trailer, making
it tough to parse out her motivations.
She appears to be an NPC, and it's even possible
that she's the game's new villain, particularly
since it seems that Cannavale's Van Pelt won't
be returning for this flick.
She certainly looks a bit sinister, although
that could simply be misdirection.
Finally, there's the smoldering Dr. Bravestone.
Remember, it's an elderly grandpa played by
Danny DeVito at the avatar's controls this
time - and the trailers suggest that if you
ever had any doubts as to how gut-bustingly
funny the Rock can be, you'll soon be putting
them to rest.
"What the hell is this?"
"It's your strengths and weaknesses."
"Smoldering intensity?"
"It's that stupid face you make."
"Huh?"
Jumanji: The Next Level is directed by Jake
Kasdan, who also helmed Welcome to the Jungle;
he co-wrote the screenplay with returning
scribes Jeff Pinkner and Scott Rosenberg.
The flick hits the big screen on December
13.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.